hello and welcome to this video playing
the gambler what is the gambler up to
hmm not much c3 the dreaded see 3 yeah
it's I mean it's not like it's super
dangerous I anything it's just not very
exciting yeah I'm going for quincy
service ism pet a little bit of a pad
line of mine probably it's not the best
line but it gets right a little bit out
of its out of his normal um yeah normal
patterns may be okay so what happens
here if I go here like Bishop g5
probably like h6 is that interesting
let's try this yeah if six hmm maybe it
goes before how that leads to funny
complications but that should be good
for black now G for the night doesn't
really have a good square i was thinking
i can take d for now however this opens
up the C file yeah I so probably should
do this so let's take this okay don't
want to take even more maybe I should
have taken this I'm really not sure
about it the heck
okay then create or a green g4 h4 he
decided on that very quickly is it ready
is it really winning night a 6 I mean
queen age 40 and definitely looks
dangerous
so he's checking 95
if I go night-night c5 here in this
position so just put in I mean wow wow
wow wow maybe you can just take 36 here
right Knight takes e4 it doesn't help me
all that much so if i take between now
here you can check on age six and then
and then I try again maybe Wow and if i
take for the ship takes probably losing
I don't see a defense actually night age
695 looks looks devastating really
district devastating this one no it's
probably using anyway Wow okay hmm
highborn was still on yeah but with the
meydan age seven I didn't see a defense
Wow okay really have to move here right
black resigns okay so what's that really
correct so I took this here here oxy one
so ok quindi eight this this allow for
Queen take c8 and that really wins
amazing I'm very big on the light
squares wow that was a cool movie my
wine it's amazing how I really did their
target one second looming for something
I mean okay it is extremely strong it's
extremely strong Jim Jim mean after that
he probably doesn't have anything good
but who goes back here Queen B 6 look
totally normal
and yeah it's no surprise that black
objectively is better here but still
quite stunned how I got killed here
after coming to be six Wow and at least
it's losing so I did not did not miss
anything here after after it hit on c8
yeah took him and I am absolutely no
defense is all this idea where it's
simply simply F block defense Wow look
take CA that's great great stuff yeah I
figured it probably out on my time I
have to go to the age really is got to
mention taking power study to notch the
coming we when we had this him if I take
yes this one this Bishop coming in champ
very very nice another idea came I mean
objectively speaking I can just take you
40 m I just wondered can I do something
else him and it is useless i have to
take I mean this is just good I have to
take a center ponyo and now I have to go
back to the eighth I wonder about this
position I mean the computer is giving
black more lesson the clear advantage
but I'm really not well developed it's
difficult i'm from white I mean without
the Queen joining the action it's not
all that danger
it's like this is the computer move and
then I go back here I just wonder if he
has something here that the computer is
this is not currently having in its
horizon okay this is a text so probably
knigu 496
like Bishop d7 rook c8 if I can
consolidate IAM like one or two moves
and I'm in excellent shape but I'm still
kind of doubtful even though the engine
is this is pretty clearly saying I do I
should be a lot better I mean after you
get got thrashed like this you need to
be a bit skeptical I will see a this is
this is cool I have absolutely no
options I mean you can always take him
okay checkmate yeah the light squeeze
the light squares are with rook c8 yeah
he gets the primary defender of the
light squares and then just just kills
me Wow very nicely done thanks for
watching